[Musique]
les restos du coeur ont lancé leur 37e
campagne d'hiver dead alimentaire avec
la crise sanitaire et la hausse du
pouvoir d'achat de nouvelles personnes
sont venues au centre de distribution de
plaisir celui ci observe une
augmentation de 40 % des bénéficiaires
treize militants appartenant au
mouvement d'ultra droite recolonisation
france ont été interpellés l'un des
membres est un colonel de gendarmerie en
poste dans les yvelines lors des
perquisitions une cinquantaine d'armes
des gilets pare balles et un exemplaire
de mein kampf ont été trouvés karim
benzema reconnu coupable de complicité
et de tentative de chantage dans la
sphère de la sextape de mathieu valbuena
l'attaquant du real madrid est condamné
à un an de prison avec sursis et 75000
euros damende un jugement rendu par le
tribunal correctionnel de versailles
cette jeune monté ombé d'aller en
direction de montpellier pour soutenir
les femmes victimes de violence leur
périple mis en images lors d'un
documentaire a permis de récolter 1600
euros pour le centre d'information sur
les droits des femmes et des familles
des yvelines
et enfin la collecte du centre
pédiatrique des côtes situées aux loges
en josas officiellement lancée retenu
pour le loto du patrimoine le site du
19e siècle doit être rénové
[Musique]